allora cari in questa partita è successa
una roba veramente mi dispiace per cesca
perché la fine sempre là in mezzo ma ho
accusato a caso ma completamente a caso
una persona ed era l'impostore però
ricordatevi dove è incredibile video
signori vuota match vuota grande play
raga questa partita è molto difficile
perché ormai siamo tutti skillati e
quindi non so effettivamente che cacchio
fare perché ormai tutti sanno è una
brutta faccenda questa è una bruttissima
faccenda però il sabotaggio non possono
anche salutare perché l'ha fatto
abbastanza
l'ha fatto troppo poco tempo fa
chi è che non mi colpì l'altro impostore
a loco lochis araba di sta qua lo puoi
uccidere ma ci sta qua perfetto via
venza pensa 2 vance doppia ventre gama
donna incredibile stavano no ero sicura
fosse marci allora io so come i riti ed
era subito sopra la porta di meteoriti
quindi secondo me so che se c'è stata
perché io appena ho visto il re actors
sono salito e ho visto il corpo è
portato a berlo riti che è lunghissima
secondo me qualcuno l'ha ucciso
e andata invent è affatto reatto può
essere io vi giuro stavo facendo la cosa
delle merendine se volete vi dico anche
che cosa stavo facendo c'era quella lì
con la pesca non lo so bene che è lui la
roma ragazzi ma veramente ma non si può
riportare un corpo disco madre ma bene
ballo ti prego
[Applauso]
ma perché deve dire queste cose
raga charlie subito sotto corrido c'è il
primo corridoio in alto partite lo sa
per la botola
io stavo per la bosnia catherine martin
gli ormai io ragazzi una paura riportare
la gente deve formare che era innocente
a me vien da dire che noi ha però non
sono sicuro perché non mi ricordo ma non
sono sicuro non sono sicuro direi
nessuno e voi imposto per una botola è
spenta loro aspetta perché carenza non
voglio uccidere questi fatti in quanto
dei questori cioè quanti ammazziamo che
noi come fai come ti permetti ma dita mi
sto dico che sto sopra il buthan lorenzo
palese dai su papa sta dicendo questa
noia
una cosa io non lavoro che saliva che
noia basta malaga non sembra di poter io
perché mi votate perché era davvero
sembrare bottle eroe era benissimo la
quarta può bastare una botola
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora ragazzi partita crew nate nella
mappa che non facciamo mai per questo
punto qualsiasi giocata io mi sto
scappando scullino sta giocando
seriamente è una mappa molto carina
ragazzi non so se avete visto la
partenza dove spiegavano come si stava
la mappa effettivamente sono stato in
grado di cavarmela oddio decontaminate
una mappa molto carina e lo so come mai
facciamo sempre la stessa
perché se ci pensate ragazzi fanno tutti
vi dò sempre sulla stessa mappa in un
gas ma ogni tanto fa bene anche variare
con la mappa nuova che non era da chissà
quanto nuova però molto carina somma non
capisco e non capirò mai come mai sono
così tanto bistrattate subito ma
lombardi domani ho capito allora come
ceska raga ma non esca c'è spazio per
ragazze e ragazzi sempre cesca la prima
partita è sempre lei butti a mare ha
capito neanche cosa
stato cesca
o no
ma come mai a fatica gare ma fate cagare
grazie
grazie perché non voglia di giocare ma
non capisco c'è scappato 5 ma come
vedete mai decollare
va benissimo
sì sì va bene sempre lei rega però
bellissimo prime partite sempre cesca
chiedo avevo difeso grazie anche maniera
14 siti la casa dei ragazzi non lo so
secondo me e martina però mi dispiace
vedere che mar
io l'ho allora è che noia io so che che
noia però non voterei mai che noia
perché poi si incazza tantissima paura
di che noi e questa la mia scusa alla
charlie non è marcino ne è sicuro che
noi amal 8.000 per cento raga come vedo
che noia devo scappare come un puledro
perché sono convinto che sia lei come si
entra qua sotto paga non vedo le porte
non le vedono le so qualcuno si sta
contaminando me ne vado alla dell'ordine
ok p4 bellissimo nora che bellissimo
task leader bellissimo
dai caso sapevo dai maledizione l'ho
visto arrivare lo sapevo che era che
noia lo sapevo che non l'hanno non l'ho
vista e non potevate votarla arrivare
prima li mannaia per come lo ha fatto
niente e io non sono mica è marcio in
passato tre bordino napoli anche avesse
preso ma era a casa accusa ma qua dice
martina ti rendi conto che mi hanno
portato fuori a caso ovvero martina più
ne rendi conto di questa cosa sordo
proprio quella di cesca era a casa da
papà che veramente schifo io non gioco
più di ragazzi con incredibile a parte
che mi dispiace mi dispiace veramente
tantissimo però non cercarmi volendo ci
vediamo un prossimo vita ragazzi mettete
gli piace è stato il commento è bella
ragazza
[Musica]